une page de cinéma pour terminer cette
édition avec à partir de mercredi sur
les écrans la fille de d'artagnan elle
s'appelle héloïse et permet à bertrand
tavernier de retrouver la grande
tradition des films de cape et d'épée
la fille dans le film c'est sophie
marceau et son père d'artagnan c'est
philippe noiret pascal deschamps andreï
sors moi qui me flatte très fort mais
des touches j'ignorais que darth rien du
tout fille nous aussi mais l'occasion
était trop belle pour philippe noiret et
bertrand tavernier complices depuis plus
de vingt ans de s'offrir enfin un film
de cape et d'épée partie de mes rêves et
il était temps que je le réalise pas ce
qu'un juge ait par l'état dans lequel
j'étais après le film il était temps un
film de cape et d'épée donc avec ses
chevauchées ces méchants son complot ses
bottes secrètes et quatre messieurs bien
tranquille mousquetaires en retraite
contraint de reprendre du service
par la faute d'une jeune fille qui ne
demande qu'à marchés sont les dignes
traces de son père héros fatigués mais
superbe la petite fille j'ai choisi
malte honneur mais je ne choisis rien du
tout
tiens regarde c'est pour ce document que
la mère supérieure les mortes
je goûte papier on a parlé à quelqu'un
qui sait tenir ma langue
c'est un secret d'état je le sais je le
sens ouais on dirait une liste de
blanchisserie tu sais avec du sort mais
une liste de blanchisserie mais c'est sa
mercedes d'assassiner un écran cent des
morts partout pour une liste de
blanchisserie mais le complot de dieu
les cavaliers noirs la femme en rouge
aurait pas aussi une licorne bleu un
petit nain vert il faut pas faire de la
parodie
il faut savoir s'amuser avec mais comme
comme dumas s'amuser avec ses
personnages puis jusque dans des romans
dramatiques comme le vicomte de
bragelonne il ya plein de passage qui
sont d'une drôlerie irrésistible
monsieur il me semble que vous avez été
imposées pour tourner ce film philippe
noiret aviles cavalier a dû pour la
première fois tâter de l'épée est ce
qu'on peut parler d'exploit physique oui
north hautement peuvent d'artagnan est
prêt pour la fille de d'artagnan le
retour où la petite fille on réduira
peut-être un peu les duels mais entre
une façon la fille de d'artagnan renoue
avec bonheur avec un genre tombé en
désuétude à la fois en le renouvelant et
dans le respect de ses cheveux blancs